vom sozialen brennpunkt hat sich dieser
17 stöckigen hochhaus komplexen
göttingen zum corona brennpunkt
entwickelt
60 der insgesamt 700 bewohner in regina
blog sollen sich bei einem
massenausbruch infiziert haben in der
stadt gibt es inzwischen 105 corinna
stelle ein 67 jähriger soll sogar schwer
erkrankt sein berichtet der ndr
der mann muss künstlich beatmet werden
das virus soll sich durch feiern mehrere
arabisch albanischer clans verbreitet
haben
die familien würden keinerlei rücksicht
nehmen erzählen menschen aus dem haus
bewohner werden angepöbelt viele haben
angst
einige bewohner wie dieses junge paar
haben sogar schon die koffer gepackt sie
fürchten die clans und corona die
großfamilien haben mehrere private
feiern abgehalten so könnte sich das
corona virus verbreitet haben ursprung
des massen aus brüssel eine illegal
geöffneter china waren göppingen sein
die stadt hat am dienstag beschlossen
alle 700 bewohner des hauses auf
bewohner zu testen doch nicht alle
erscheinen
stattdessen droht die stimmung im
hochhaus zu kämpfen journalisten werden
vom balkon aus mit kartoffeln beworfen
ein journalist wird von einem geschoss
getroffen es folgt eine anzeige wegen
körperverletzung polizei muss sogar mit
mehreren mannschaftswagen andrücken
nördlingens schulen reagieren auf diesen
chor ohne ausbruch und passen ihre
sicherheitsvorkehrungen an
abgesehen von klassenräumen muss nun auf
dem schulgelände einen mund- und
nasenschutz getragen werden wir nun aus
götting zugeschaltet mein kollege
stephan siewering stefan ihr wart
gestern vor ort steht jetzt heute aber
etwas weiter weg was genau ist gestern
in götting passiert ja die stimmung in
diesem hochhaus ist sehr aggressiv
gewesen gestern die bewohner haben vom
balkon herunter mit kartoffeln tomaten
eiern geworfen
ich habe selbst eine kartoffel vor die
füße bekommen ein kamera kollege wurde
am knöchel getroffen jetzt löcher wurde
dick und hat jetzt auch körperverletzung
anzeige erstattet die polizei musste
sogar an rücken und passanten und die
journalisten schützen die kann mit
schilden und mehreren mannschaftswagen
also es ist eine sehr aggressive
stimmung hier in diesem hohen block wenn
wir gerade gesehen ist soll jetzt ein
corona test für das ganze hochhaus geben
aber nicht jedes gekommen was passiert
jetzt mit den menschen die sich
geweigert haben sich testen zu lassen
es geht jetzt schon an dass jetzt die
ersten hier abgeholt werden das sind
aber erstmal die bettlägerigen und alten
und kranken die werden zur
universitätsmedizin göttingen gefahren
wird das zentrum ist in den nächsten
tagen also bis zum wochenende sollen
hier zwei testzentren errichtet werden
und dann mit hilfe von
sicherheitsbeamten und polizei werden
dann die bewohner gebeten 1
herauszukommen und werde nicht kommt
wird mit der polizei herausgeholt